تتشابه اعوام الفلسطينيين تحت الاحتلال
لكن عامهم الذي سبق هذا كان له تصنيف خاص
ليس اصحاب الارض والقضيه من صنفوه بل هي
الامم المتحده من قالت عن عام 2022 انه
كان الاكثر دمويه منذ بدات المنظمه في
احصاء شهداء فلسطين بشكل منهجي عام 2005
الى ان العمل الماضي شهيد رقما قياسيا من
اعمال العنف الاسرائيليه خصوصا في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله
جرائم الاحتلال التي كانت تنفذ اما برصاص
الجيش او خلال اعتداءات مستوطنين يهود
اوصلت عدد الشهداء الفلسطينيين عام 2022
الى نحو 130 من بينهم 44 طفل
على ماذا عامل من تولي حكومه بنت لابيد
السلطه في اسرائيل فووطات كما يبدو
لزمزياح نحو اليمين زادت وتيره جرائم
الاحتلال
يذكر المقررون الامويون في بيانهم اسرائيل
بانه في انتظار تفكيك احتلالها غير
القانوني فيجب معامله الفلسطينيين في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله كاشخاص
المحميين وليس كاعداء او ارهابيين الواقعه
امر اخر والا لما شاهدنا مثلا اغتيالات في
الشوارع وعلى الحواجز الامنيه
ولما تكفت عمليات الذهب والاعتقال وتجريف
الاراضي وهدم المنازل او مصادرتها
زاد في تلك الفتره الدفع قدما بمخططات
الاستيطان نحو التنفيذ
واستمرت محاصره قطاع غزه مع ابقائه في
حاله من الضغط الاميه والاقتصادي الدائم
كما توالت اقتحامات المسجد الاقصى دون
مراعاه لمشاعر العرب والمسلمين
كانت اعين العالم تراقب والسنته تدين عنف
المستوطنين حين وحينا استخدام القوات
الاسرائيليه ما يوصف بالعنف المفرطي ضد
الفلسطينيين
لم تخرج المواقف الاوروبيه عن تلك الدائره
مع التحذير من عواقب استمرار مسلسل
حكومه اسرائيليه جديده تسير على هدى من
اليمين المتطرف والصهيونيه الدينيه
حكومه
برنامجها القائمه على توسيع الاستيطان
وتشديد السيطره على القدس
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي الذي زار
المنطقه دعا الى تهدئه
عبر لتل ابيب ايضا عن قلق اداره جو بايدن
من مخططات الحكومه الجديده بشان توسيع
المستوطنات اليهوديه في الضفه الغربيه